Testing on a small number of people has been underway in Russia for less than two months,...
...and there's been no scientific data made public on any of it.
Nonetheless, from Vladimir Putin today, a stunner.
Russia, he said, has approved the first vaccine for the coronavirus infection...
...nicknamed Sputnik V for Sputnik vaccine...
...after the Russian space satellite that in 1957 beat the world into orbit.
Russia even put out this video today referencing the namesake,...
...but there are myriad questions and concerns already.
A vaccine so quickly and from a country notorious for propaganda and deception...
...has many worrying not only does it work, but is it safe?